In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful
[Music] By
coincidence, there is a company here in the Smart Village, so
I wanted to film the video to show
you the
frankness, which is very nice, but the weather today is
terribly hot. We are in 2014.
I am here in front of us here at Telecom Egypt,
at
Intra, at Exceed, at the Egyptian Post.
In Microsoft
and in Data Link, almost all of these companies
are on Google. I mean, the
atmosphere is very difficult
here. They say that the ministry building is the
Ministry of Communications. I mean, this is a walking man. There is no
one to call him. There is a school here. A
school called Smart.
This is the entrance to the gate. I enter through it and find
myself
arriving to enter here. I think it is best to  We
have a stroller with us so that I can move around, because I
walk here alone. This is very difficult, as we
see. The Ministry of Communications and
Information Technology
would like me to take you with me until I reach the
door outside so that I can show you what it is like to enter the
smart village.
They say here there is a bus that can take
you to the engineers.  And you may ride Ramses or
something like that, but I almost never caught a
bus called Rama, and
the project,
but I think the atmosphere here is beautiful. Just being
in Dot area means it
makes him a little
happy. [Applause] Why, why don't they all stay like this? I mean, there's
greenery
in the well-organized streets
in...  The buildings look respectable, there is security
in traffic,
in anything. I mean, the person feels that he is in
the worst days of his life,
not even one of your days. No, no, I don’t want to say this is the
gate of the smart village. Until
now, I’m still walking. I love all this, of course, and the sun is
on my back. I don’t think it’s you.  You still
feel something like this.
I just feel it. Oh,
here at Banque Misr as well. Of course he is in
Mobinil Vodafone and all the telecommunications companies. I mean,
this is a school. He says that I am now my mother’s. We are
adding between you and me. I mean, don’t tell anyone who
follows Ahmed Nazif. I spoke to
someone I found him telling me that she is.  There are salaries here that reach a
million pounds a month, 700 thousand. I
don't want to tell you how I work at the time. Do
you see what the logo of the police is like? What is this in Egypt? What else is needed in Etisalat? Ok, I will show you
the view from afar so we can see the entrance to the
only village from which you can fear.
I was coming from Alexandria. I expected
that I could enter from any place.
This is the name of it. I enter here. All the
companies enter. They enter.
The person exits. Why did
n’t he come in a nice car? Isn’t that the case in a post office as well? It is, by God, good. But I think that is enough because not only I. I will be
roasted.  The mobile phone will also be roasted
for me. Thank you. If you need anything else, you can
respond to me in the comments of the video. I will respond
to you, according to my moderate experience.